From the streaming studio with an infinite money code comes a film made for the
new home of action. Blockbusters, your couch,
the old guard you've seen Netflix turnout, disposable, romcoms,
Oscar baiting dramas,
and the home movies from Adam Sandler's least hilarious vacations. Now,
whatever AI they use to make programming decisions has found a new way to make
you look up from your phone for two minutes so they can count it.
As of you take an ALA star and cram them into a B movie action flake.
Nope, not that one. Not that one. That one. Not that one.
There it is. As the studio spends big money on talent and uses.
Whatever's left to cram action into an affordably tiny space.
Don't you guys want to go fight outside. It's such a nice day.
Meet the old guard,
a team of immortal mercenaries who can revive themselves with the power of
moaning and grunting real hall.
Uh.
Just got to resurrect my pancreas real quick.
Crap rebirth crap.
These Illuma hotties have lived for hundreds to thousands of years with a
burning desire to do good, even though they're really bad.
We've done nothing. The world isn't getting any better.
It's getting worse because.
They spend an eternity learning problem. A Gar boning celebrity.
Is this the Rodin? Did you know him.
Biblically and developing their palette?
Not Walnut black sea Rose water pomegranate Eastern
Turkey.
They're not even that good at fighting.
Normally normies get the drop on them all the time.
Yeah.
This is just poor immortal time management me team leader, Andy,
in a role that lets her Lee stretch her range from world weary.
We can do something.
Good. Some good means nothing too exhausted. I gave up searching for her to.
Amine old Rumpelstiltskin, the broken.
Burn for all.
She straddles the crossroads of being the next Kiano Reis or being the next
Gerard Butler of action movies.
She's the leader of an unable to commit suicide squad featuring newcomer,
Nile, a Marine trained in expedition.
So why is this happening to me? How are you out of them on trains? What's that.
Booker? Who likes books? Oh, first edition.
Don't chaotic and a pair of passionately medieval warrior lovers.
He's the moon when I'm lost in darkness and warmth.
When I share for wrinkles in his case still thrills me even after millennia.
As if eternal life wasn't already enough of a girls' match.
And at single next to a lovey-dovey couple here.
Curable, romantic, kill me.
Together.
Charlie's his angels will find their very own Bosley and unite to take down a
guy who combines the dickish penis of Mark Zuckerberg from the social network
with a wardrobe of Justin Timberlake from the social network.
So strap in for a history spanning Epic full of intense action scenes,
except the heroes have every advantage.
And the villains are chump underdogs with zero chance that proves an all female
crew behind the camera can get it done just as well as the fellows,
but due to the realities of streaming budgets mostly takes place in small rooms
next to something more exciting.
I thought you said we were going to Paris or just outside of Paris.
I felt that it was just outside of London and a van in mine.
Wow.
And pumps the brakes on the thrills to set up some sequels because Netflix is
Skynet has already perceived.
This will become your new favorite franchise and resistance is futile.
Then let's go to work, but Hey, we all have Shirley Sarone and axes.
What could go wrong? Right
story. Shirley's he on? If Beale street couldn't die,
schmuck, everlasting, Jafar and away, the cutest Mediterranean sniper.
She would tell NGO, Gord pharma, bro,
and iron man.
Excellent.
Bad boys for life.
[Inaudible].
Thousands of years old. And that's your big catch phrase. See,
that's why you carry around a little notebook to jot ideas down on the go.
Want more old guard,
click the box to see how we rated every Netflix original action movie.
So you can decide what to watch. Go, boom.
Next this tea is nothing more than hot leaf juice.
If life isn't a video game, stop giving me fetch quests mother,
the new Chalupa box from taco bell.